so I'm Jim from LA and I don't speak
Spanish so I don't no idea what's
happening just now so I would just keep
talking and if these sessions is over
somebody please stop me all right so
today I first of all welcome to this
session and today I will talk about how
to write if effective patient programs
using intensive row intensive
probability so first of all if you have
your laptop here I highly encourage you
to follow this collab so there was this
is a shop link that you can follow and
it already had the environment set up
code block so you just run the first two
blocks basically what it does here is it
upgrades the tensor flow to the tune I
leave you and also tensorflow
probability and also I will be using
others to do all the protein and the
Diagnostics right does everybody get the
shock ring or it might you need a few
minutes okay so while you are setting up
the environment and I hope that it works
a little bit of about myself so I'm
currently a data scientist in Google so
I based in Zurich and I am not
officially part of the tensorflow
mobility team although I work very
closely with them in terms of like a PID
size and also how to use it to to write
programs specifically to do data
analysis so this kind of like how you
use tensor flow in terms of ability in
your day to day data science jobs and
first people before I start please
show a hand if you have ever used any
kinds of patient programs for example if
you have used pythons times III or you
have used stands from our yeah priests
show of hands right thank you and how
many of you have kind of some basic
knowledge of what what patient
programming is trying to do or
probabilistic programming in general
okay great
so if for those of you have never used
to have never do patients antistick
before or you have never kind of write
any or you know the basics but you never
actually write on a model
don't be afraid especially in the
beginning you might feel like this
tutorial is kind of life just threw you
in the deep end of the water I asked you
to take kind of a leap of faith and just
try to follow the call and try to run
the call because I guess everybody here
knows Python and you find that is
actually you get intuitions from running
the call and try to mess it around and
debug it much better than just read the
book and try to learn patience and
sistas right okay so in terms of like
too impatient scientist is the key here
is we want to follow this kind of box
loop so basically the idea is that you
first gather some data from some viewer
view all phenomenons and then you cycle
through this box loop basically you try
to peel a probabilistic model and then
you you feed the data to the public
publicity models and then you do a
criticism so for example is the the
parameter fitted is it make sense is is
is it makes good posteriors predictions
is it is it gives the the sample is
actually high quality
and it's a model actually capture all
the information you have and it's kind
of like real a realistic representation
of your current knowledge and as kind of
a more advanced version is this kind of
modern patient workflow and is is kind
of like an extension of the pops look so
now that the key part here is that you
would have this workflow not just it's
not only helping you to build a model
but it also helps you to know that
whether you are incorporating the prior
information correctly into it so if you
look at this kind of like larger
flowchart you will find that kind of
some of the key component in terms of
what the publicity model should teach
you is that you should be able to
simulate fake data and you should be you
should have a kind of coherent workflow
that you can inference the model and
then once you think that the model is
good then you can use the inference
result usually I prefer to use the MCMC
sample and then as a representation of
the the model and inference that I have
and then plug it in into for example
some objective function to help me to
make actual decisions so the aim of
today is I want to show you how to write
this effective Kabbalistic model in
terms of all probability and the kind of
the key point here is you need to think
in terms of patch so patch in this case
is that you have some kind of program
and you want to run it in parallel
across a lot of kind of copy of itself
and each of them has a little bit
different state but they are all the
represent or the same representation of
the problem that you set up for example
one of the kind of classical example in
this case would be you running them out
among Monte Carlo Markov chain and then
you have multiple team so each chain for
example if you
1010 chains and each of them would be
one batch and the second point is if you
want to have a fast tensorflow program
usually we want to make sure that is a
compiled SLA is kind of this linear
algebra accelerations special compiler
that is designed initially for TPU
but it actually keeps a great speed up
also for GPU and if you if you are able
to make your program that compiled SLA
you means that once when you want to run
it on GPU or when you want to run it on
TV you that they will all be compatible
and you have no problem across hardware
and it gives you like great speed up
actually before in the beginning when I
was preparing for this talk SLA was much
more difficult to use and now you can
just do in your TF top tongue function
wrapper you can just put this
experimental compile as true and then
you will automatically compiled SLA so
basically I almost cut all the tutorial
half because now it's just so much
easier to use and this tutorial is
largely based on modeling with joint
distribution so today we will use mostly
the TF tensile probability distribution
or join joint distribution as a main API
that we will be interacting and writing
programs right so first of all a small
primer of using linear regression so a
linear regression problems that we all
love a knows is that you know most
simplistic one we have kind of three two
parameters if you are thinking in a more
frequent statistic scientist is a sense
you have the intercept and coefficient
so in numpy or Syfy you can generate a
fake data set
this so you have the koi fish covariant
all the predictors and you would have
the parameters here and then you can
just do this simulate one data set and
usually we'll see notation something
like this and basically this means that
you're absurd data is some kind of
linear predictions plus some noise and
then in a classical kind of if you're
doing frequency censuses then you will
have an estimator in this case least
least square estimator by doing some
projection of your data to just this
kind of space the set up by the
Biodesign matrix and you can easily
write it into well easily if you know
you can kind of rethink it in a
different ways of like more a generative
model kind of thinking which means that
all the three parameters we have we now
think of it as generated from some from
some prior distribution so again here I
asked you to take a big leap of faith
just look at this prior as some
arbitrary prior that you set up so in
reality when you're actually doing
practical patience and thesis choosing
the correct or while choosing a prior
that reflects your prior knowledge
correctly takes basically takes practice
and you you know better since you go
around but in the beginning just take a
leap of faith and just assign it with
some arbitrary priors and once you set a
sign laboratory prior to it then you can
generate data because all the kind of
this distribution it all comes with a
random number generator and then you can
general generate data from it and you
will just plug in the information you
know in this case is the predictors and
you can have your observe
distribution of the photo for the actual
obser usually people call this as a
livelihood and this is the kind of like
the whole model you have so in a kind of
line of vanilla way of writing intensive
role program you would basically need to
write this model two times once in this
kind of forward random if you want to
generate data and once in this kind of
reverse to generate a lot likelihood
function when you try to do inference so
to write a foreword random generations
you do something similar to this so you
might recognize some of the kind of
rhyme or standard of things which is
something i TFD talk normal which is set
up the distribution so i would quickly
go back a little bit to show you that
the import here so first of all i would
import the tensorflow and ten circle
probability this is a really kind of
good things to use because if you import
a compact or with you as tensorflow i
think most of the new release of
tensorflow this will put you into the
tencel 2.0 api which means that once
that becomes the mainstream you can just
remove you can just change you change it
into importance of role as TF and your
code will works continuously for quite
quite a bit of time and also two
important thing is i I said set it TR t
equal to tens of our ability talk
distributions so now it contains that
the module of distributions and also I
have the TLP talk by objectors so this
concepts you might be familiar with
distributions but by chapters in my
son's a little little bit of lie
foreign concepts so the projectors a
module of transformations that preserves
volumes and again I've asked you to take
a little bit leap of faith when we come
across it for now let's just stick with
the distributions and and see that
what it has
apologize I'm not using my own computer
so like holding is it's quite risky so
we'll explain to you a little bit of
what it has actually yes look at normal
maybe this would be give us a little bit
more information right so basically it
has some parameter amortizations and it
has a valid a underscore arguments is a
good practice to send it to true
especially when you are setting up like
more complicated distributions and then
you also can assign a name so the name
is just for for this node to appear in a
tensor for graph and is useful when you
are doing the packing of your models or
tensorflow programs in general and you
can see all the information from here it
has it has a kind of lots of different
properties probably easier if
so it contains useful property the most
most will be using a stock sample
because this gift gives us a random
sample or random realization from the
distributions for example you will see
something like this basically it's a 5/5
you can think of it as file random draw
from these distributions so when it when
it comes to distribution it has this big
concept of shape so here I would I would
kind of light touch it a little bit but
kind of a more formal introduction you
also need to do some readings afterward
because is a concept that is at times it
could be quite confusing and one of the
signature of the distribution is that
when you do samples and then you can
always plug it back in into the log plot
so if you are implementing a
distribution on your own a very good way
to check that whether it works is that
you plug it strictly back in into the
log crock and and basically check to
make sure at least the shape is correct
right so now after this small sign osan
on distribution we can go back to our
program of doing just to try to set up
this forward kind of like the random
generations so you do samples here I
pass it an arguments of number of
replicas so basically it means that how
many samples I want to generate from
these distributions and the first three
lines in a way is directly respond
correspondent to the priors because this
you don't need any dependents in a way
so once you set up the distribution is
stea as it's a very concrete kind of
object and you just do sample from from
it and then you will plug it in into
linear functions and here I need to do
some chuckling of the shape because
otherwise it
give me the correct result and also for
the for the last one when I set up a
light liquid and here one of the things
that you might notice is that and I will
only do sample ones here
the reason being that there's some
broadcasting happening here because the
X here now is the number of observation
we have and if we have the number of
replicas basically what we want to
broadcast it into the shape of the your
number of observation and the replica
you have so that's kind of like the
first point of lie apart thinking
because alternate Airy what we can do is
we don't put this argument and just draw
once and the program will work and you
don't kind of you don't need to kind of
worry about the shapes but will but then
if you want to repeat regenerate to
tease forward generations you might need
to write into a folder of course there's
other ways to do it because this is a
embarrassed paralyzed program so you
might be able to use a path for and it's
also a valid thing to do but in general
if you think ahead of like all what is
the patch should be or a know what the
shape should be in this case you would
generally take the full advantage of
attentional probability programs now so
after I set up these functions I can do
a forward generation of destroy nine and
of random example from it and I can proc
it so this would be my prior predicted
distribution or some prior predicted
samples to tell you what my public
program looks like if I draw sample from
it
and then so that that is fall it's kind
of like the first part of what what you
would be expecting from a publicity
program is that they can draw a random
sample or you can generate random
observations and then it's the part of
you're actually setting up a lot of
likelihood function which you use it for
doing inference so in this case the
first three is it looks very similar to
what you you are writing in the forward
sampling program the differences is that
now you actually pass in the unknowns
that you have for this model and then
you will evaluate the log prop and then
again the linear function is actually
the same because they are all tensor so
you also need to make sure that the
broadcasting is happening correctly and
last you setup the likelihood in a
really similar way but instead of sample
you evaluate a lockbox on your
observations and is probably a better
practice also is to is to put the lock
locks all your observation here and and
when you are actually doing inference
you make it into a closure so that it
doesn't require your observations all
the time it doesn't require you to
supply lock observational time and if
you look at the return here something
you might notice that is am I needed to
reduce some because otherwise it
wouldn't keep me in the correct result
the reason being that if you just
execute this the the likelihood naively
you get the other shape would be
different
so by what what I meant is that what you
can try is to comment out this and give
this into just output or the the lock
lock so each part of the lock lock and I
also remove
the reduce some at the end common tees
actually I would just print a shape so
because that's what we would be we want
to know
okay so now you see that because before
we call that we are drawing nice samples
from it and now I want you once you
evaluate it you find that the last one
has a different shape than the others
and the kind of line the best case
scenario if you do it this way and do
just do the sum is that if you flew you
an error because it tells you or I
cannot broadcast this but a worst case
is that actually you might have some
scalar somewhere and it got broadcast to
the to your pro and give you a incorrect
result
and so that's kind of like the first
check you should do when you're writing
this vanilla kind of lot of functions
and and a lot of things that is the good
thing of writing in in a batch is that
now you can evaluate on a really large
arrays and then it's you can actually do
this kind of research by really stupidly
especially when you are in a low
dimension space and is great way to
visualize your publicity programs for
example what I'm doing here is that I
set up a grid of one of the two of the
run are the parameters I'm interested in
and I fixed the kind of the error or the
epsilon into one and I keep it a range
of all actually I think the betas will
be in this range and intercept will be
in this range and then I've frightened
it and evaluate on the lock locks as you
can see here and it will keep you and
then after we shape it into a square and
it will keep you this kind of light
landscape all the geometry of the log
likelihood functions and in general I
find it it's a really good way to check
especially when you have problems doing
sampling it's a really good way to check
whether the space actually looks kind of
okay because if you have multi multi
multiple mole in your posterior space
it's always very difficult to sample so
right so that's kind of like a really
quick primer of how you will write down
a publicity programs intensive role
using this really low-level API so
basically you write a lot lot of
functions and you write your forward
generated functions and it is if you if
you kind of like know everything that
you want to do you have live controls to
the last detail
but at the same time is really tedious
and sometimes if you write if you make a
mistake in one of the functions then is
it might be it might get quite difficult
to debug so now let's move on to to also
a linear regression example but now
we're using the API from the joint
distributions so I'm using the data set
from one of the pansy documentary so you
can look at you can follow the link
afterwards to get basically get some
background information from it but
basically the OP the data we are we are
we have it looks like this and you can
see that some outliers here and in this
data set each of the observation comes
with its own error so in use only be
setting up a model that we interested in
two parameter the intercept of the
linear regression and a coefficient of
the linear regression
so now if you are writing it down in
joint distributions I the favorite API I
will use is the sequential here
basically you pass a list of either this
list of other distribution or a lambda
function to the initialization of this
class and you can look let's look at the
line by line of the signature of how you
would write down a probabilistic program
so you have two prior here b0 is the
intercept and b1 is the coefficients and
then you write down these lambda
functions that basically declare what is
the dependency of the inputs and how you
would use this dependency to return a
distribution so for example here b0 is
the intercept and P 1 is the coefficient
and kind of like a small really
important detail is that you always need
to pass it as the order closest so the
first argument is that it needs to be
the distribution closest to the ones
that you're writing right now so for
example you have B 0 B 1 and here
because the B 1 because the next one is
directly after the Beast
B 1 so you need to put this as the first
argument and if you have something like
for example you have other other
distribution here for example say that
we actually also want to model the Sigma
and we give it some other some prior
distributions of something like this for
the program to work correctly you
actually don't need to put the last one
here but imagine now that if you have
this being in the middle of the two
parameters sorry
so now imagine that this prior
distribution is actually in the middle
you what you can do is you can put this
underscore
so just to declare that you'll you don't
need in this argument but is it does no
harm to also put this in this one of
course if you put this in than in
inference you also need to modify the
list of inputs you actually goes into
your log prop functions so now we can
run this program and first thing we will
do is to check the graph of the model to
see the dependencies so for example if
you do it this way of resolving an
underlying graph you will show you that
we have a two prior distribution that it
is not dependent or it does not have any
dependencies and then we have the
likelihood that is parameterize by the
two three parameters and X here is the
last node is kind of like currently you
cannot change name but if you use other
Joint Distribution API you can change
the name here and now you can we can
also do sample from it and this is what
we looks like when we do one samples so
here it gives a list of tensors
administer here is not too close and you
can also plug it in directly into the
lowepro function to computer of the log
drop and if we do so we actually sees
that the shape is wrong here this wrong
because we are only sample it once so
which means that we should be getting
back the log plot also of being a scalar
so here is kind of like the first
concept of a patch is that because when
you do samples in this context at least
is a patch of random samples and we
should expect it to always
which is the same shape when we do the
Doppler problem so here is that you can
we can further check the where is going
wrong by calling the dot a lot product
underscore path which return each pack
of the log plot functions that in this
holistic models and we can see that
maybe not super obvious but the last one
because we have some multiplications in
the in there where we set up linear
predictions now step the shape is
incorrect because we actually want to do
a reduce some the last for the last
random variables so the trick here to
make this works is to use something
called TF detour independent which it
really interpret what's the bad shape
and in another world
is that it it's basically tells you you
tell the program where in which in which
dimension you should to further reduce
some to make sure that the output is
correct and in the beginning in my take
some try never but probably at least for
me to figure this out like kind of like
a really quick way is just to try
different we read interpret interpret
patch dimensions to make sure that when
you actually call now that if you do
to example of some batch and then do
then evaluate a lock lock it should give
you the same shape
okay let's move on from this one now
actually we can try to see that what
still happening here
right so this doesn't work right now
because we are doing the multiplications
and here what's happening is that this
is a scalar so when you do a broadcast
under under under knee to do that to get
the linear predictions is incompatible
so this which is what is trying to tell
us here and in general at least from
beginning to kind of like quickly fix
this is that the arbitrary expand the
dimension here so for example because we
are drawing five drawers from here and
the key is to make this work because now
this one it has a shape of 20 and this
one has the shape of 500 or any of your
bar shapes you are you are trying to
you're trying to draw so which means
that B ones it has the shape of
basically just a bad shape
and as for X we have a different shape
which is the what's inherent from the
from the problem set ups that we have so
which is the number of observations and
what we want
after we want from the list for the
linear predictors to work or the linear
function to work is that we want to get
the shape
and the number of observations
so which means in this case to make it
work we can arbitrarily expand this into
for example if you make this into shape
of bad shape one and make this into one
and number of observations then it will
get broadcast correctly so I you can try
it yourself and that's kind of like the
way of debugging a model when you have
incompatible shape in in the middle of
your models and of course for B 0 you
also need to expand shape also likely
for the Sigma's because otherwise you
always complain that you cannot set this
up correctly
and a better style to write this is -
you have generate you have a function to
generate a model so that you would you
you can change for example hyper has
some hybrid parameters much easier and
you can do other setups a bit easier as
well and here it's not going to work as
well because because we also have
incompatible shape and I will come to
Archy
so I would have to correctly writing
about shapes later so here because we
don't have them we don't do the
broadcast incorrectly so this we still
keeps you and ever if you want to to
kind of draw a batch from it
so right now we are still dealing with a
probabilistic model that is not much
compared to go but we can already use
this program to do inference so one of
the API is that we can use is I will
skip this path so this is just an FYI
that there was other ways to - there's
other kind of joint distribution that
you can use but I will quickly skip this
for now and show you how you can use
this the model to do for example
inference so sensible probability comes
with the optimizer one of it is the
really famous l-bfgs and you can do this
kind of maximum likelihood estimation or
mass maximum or posterior estimations so
what you do is that you first set up the
negative log likelihood functions now we
we need to first generate a closer which
means that because the observation is
kind of like fakes so we we just have
the free parameters comes from the input
and I think right now it's due the case
that the optimizer it needs to take
basically one tenth of Rho a tensor as
as input to the function so you would
also do some shape or slice the inputs
shenanigan here and to call the api's
you you just do you just pass the
log-likelihood here the the I do it is
as a negative log likelihood because
he's trying to find the maximum
so I do the negative here and also I
need to wrap it in a TFP don't math
value and gradian wrapper this will
actually generate not just the kind of
the loss function but also the gradient
with respect to the inputs so now if you
run this the result is in precision and
then you do you can do convert it to
numpy and this we can prop what is the
pole at the feet of the model so this is
how it looks like and of course because
we have outlier here and with a Gaussian
likelihood it would just have this kind
of like bias curve a fitted model and
now that remember that before our Chi
here that has want to have like a patch
version work we need to do this kind of
[ __ ] expansion to make sure that the
shape is correct
so because that we want to want it to be
broadcast correctly so we always need to
kind of like part that the dimension of
those that is incompatible and do this
poke poke keep in on a piece of paper or
in your head and to make sure that you
you get back a hope of joint
distribution that it can actually sample
a batch from it so now this one will
work as a batch version and we can also
check it from by doing this sample
distribution so it not only comes back
with the samples also comes back with
the distribution which you can further
check what the shape is I will skip this
part for now because if we go into
detail shapes it's going to take us a
whole day but at least like intuitively
how you will check this kind of program
is always two samples and then you
evaluate a lot of products and if this
pass you would have you basically means
that you have a correct
Graham setup so in this case you can see
that all the random variables it has the
correct shape and when you do the sum
they will be also broadcast correctly
and again here I wrap into a function
but here I also do a little bit
different tricks here because remember
that in this case we always kind of like
all we need to think about how the
broadcasting works because otherwise
it's not going to do to reduce some
correctly and also when you plug it in
into a linear function it would give you
a lot of trouble complaining so one way
to kind of a core and it is used is
called T of these samples is in general
a great way when you have some
distribution but it's in this kind of
repeat measurements sense so if one of
the example would be you're testing
you're doing a mixed effect model and
you have for example you're doing some
kind of survey and you have number of
people response and you have some common
parameters and you want to broadcast it
into all the response that you have and
using talk samples basically keep you
you always give you the correct reduce
some when you can't compute a lot
particle in a nice case in this case is
that now this instead of being a scalar
distribution is actually we is a shape
one vector and then it will do the
broadcast incorrectly
and also you don't need to do this
pattern of the of your parameters of
course we still need to do some shape
padding on the input because they still
have the wrong shape
but this now this will work kind of more
naturally so this is kind of like the
first I would say a tip is that when you
have scalar functions or scalar
distribution and you want to make it
into something that is easier to work
with in a batch is that you just sample
one somatic in terms of like what the
distribution is is almost identical it
just the output shape is now different
and some small sign out here is that
sometimes we might not be able to always
write a function that is kind of like
this batch version for example some of
the OTE models is only defined it's
really difficult to make it into a batch
and there are also a helper function to
do that for example you can do this
TF don't vectorize map that so that
should be always the first thing you try
because it is the fastest way to
vectorize the your function and if that
doesn't work for example you have some
dynamic shape somewhere and you can use
this map underscore FN and it also does
similar thing but it's kind of like a
higher tor array of your tentacle
function but the cause of of course is
that it runs a quite high locks lower as
well
and here it's just like I wrote this
small helper function to validate the
law probe to make sure that the shape is
always the same as the previous one but
I think that if you put down valid a
argument as true in setting up your
distribution is to do something very
similar right now that since we have
this kind of patched version of models
and we can have a batch version or block
prop functions it's much easier to do
Markov chain Monte Carlo because all the
API is the intensive of probability in
this MCMC module is that they always
have have this capacity that you can
pass in a patched version or block block
and one of the kind of a key thing of a
change of thinking is that for example
when I'm I'm writing a prime C 3 models
usually the number of chains that I can
sample efficiently is bounded by the
number of CPU I have because that's
basically how it works that in times
free we compiled a lot of functions we
compile the sample in kind of pine line
and then we just pick all it and send it
to different CPUs similar conceptually
also for stan is that it needs the
number of cores to do an independent
independent chain otherwise you would to
sample it sequential and there's a big
difference when we look at tensorflow
programs because the patch is kind of
like a really kind of like the
first-class citizen in a sense that is
highly optimized so that even when you
just have one CPU or one GPUs it can run
a batch version much quicker and
sometimes you can run tens of thousands
of batch in a course or similar to just
run in five parts so whenever possible
always try to set the number of chains
much larger here I only set it to ten
but is it you can easily set it to a
hundred and it was to steal sample
quickly and I also write it is helper
functions to do sampling z' from the
nasa samples and right now there's a lot
of boilerplate code because we are still
in a ways that tensor probability is a
really low level library so that it
gives you all the the the things that
you can do kind of lots of possibility
but also it doesn't have that much of
high level API yet so if I want to use
the sample ins one of the signature is
that you would always pass in you always
need a lot of prop functions and you
will also need some additional arguments
that related to the sample that you are
using so here I'll be using the node no
you turn samples and what it needs is
the initial step size and if you need to
specify the target locked or functions
so I will do this set up kind of like
outside of the the run chain functions
by first doing the sample so this would
be my initial state and the step size I
just do it aside in an arbitrary point
want and is we will do some steps i
adaptations in the middle of the program
so it will kind of choose the steps i
most Mochrie but there are still some
kind of like there's quite a lot of
trying error when you're trying to get
the correct step size in a ways that it
has right scale i will come to if we
have time we will go through like how to
do these adaptations much better similar
to what time see free or stan is doing
later on and then we'll set up a lock
lock function which now we are using the
lock prop from the model but of course
because we have some observed data so we
need to generate this closure of
lambda function so that is now
conditioned on the absurd data's that we
have and I also give you the projector
here I will skip here for now because
I'm just using an identity by ejector
the reason I'm doing that is because
later on we will have an example that
actually use we need a by ejector that
is actually transfer kind of line map in
the parameter parameter into a
continuous space but right now you just
look we just look at it as one argument
we can pass in into this function that
we do sampling and here is kind of not a
magic that make sure to make the program
run fast is you wrap everything into TF
dot function now that it will compile
graph and because I have experimental
compiles true it also compiled SLA I
usually will put autograft equal false
in the in the as a kind of relative
fault because in terms of probability we
have a lot of places that we have a for
loop but it's running kind of lightly
iterated through a static input and if
you have Auto grab as true it would try
to also automatically convert those into
into the graph which I actually don't
want here so that's why I always put
autograph equal false but the
consequence of doing this is that if
your program actually has a followed and
you want to make it into like a fast
faster version with autograph
that is not going to work and it
actually would generate a huge graph so
in general that my recommendation or I
think a bad test hi practice is that if
possible you should always write remove
all your four loops unless you're sure
that that's needed so if you have
followed s actually doing computation
you should always try to rewrite it into
a TF dot while loops or if you need each
each step of the while of
the follow then you will ride it into TF
dog scan okay so here there's a lot of
calls so I will not go through
everything one of the things that I'm
not going into too much detail is
setting up of this - origin steps are
adaptation so for now just think of it
as some things that you will always do
to try to kind of improve the efficiency
of the sample and this is however this
is actually important is having a trace
function so a trace function is that not
only that you are getting the samples
but you're also getting this kind of
metadata from the sample for example
here I will get in the target lock lock
which basically means that each sample
is evaluated on the lock probe what is
the outcome on each step number of leap
frogs have been taken that is just kind
of like useful things to knows for nuts
no u-turn sampler - to know how
efficient your program is and how you
can improve and whether it has divergent
as an energy there's also a concept that
is highly related to not sample so if
you are not familiar with this concept
take a leap of faith let's move on from
here for now and the function signature
between samples is that you will pass in
the kernels so before here I is all for
setting up a transitional kernels and
you have the number of steps which this
is the actual number of MCMC samples you
will get and you will have the burning
which is tightly related to the steps
are adaptations and other things you
need is you always need to pass the
initial state which you tell the program
where the Markov chain Monte Carlo to
start in the posterior distributions or
the space that is set up by the
posterior and a trace function which is
the kind of like this metadata you want
to keep track from doctor insist
kernels and now that we have this
function set up we can do sample from it
and here I'm just setting the initial
stage the step size and the target lock
box and here you can disregard this for
now and I'll be using others as to
display the result so here there was
also again some boilerplate code to to
name the results correctly so when it
translate into obvious trace or obvious
data it has correct labels and the
correct kind of dimensions for the what
is a chain and what is the the draws and
we can take full advantage of it to do
to display the result for example we can
do trace products we can do forest probe
look at the energy Prague or whatnot and
we can also look at kind of reconstruct
the prediction function in a spirit
that's similar to what a posterior
predictive sample would do
now let's change key a little bit still
with our example but now we actually
want a robust linear regression so we
put it as a student team model the
differences here is that we changed the
likelihood because the likelihood of a
normal night Lee hood it doesn't take
into account of this outlier already in
a good ways so by using a slightly more
heavy tailed distribution
now that all the we kind of learn more
tolerate that we might have some
observations that is just doesn't look
like the others so in a way is kind of
like our liar so the first few parts is
still looks really similar to what we
have previously so is the code to
coefficients
and for the degrees of freedoms because
for a student heat distribution we need
to specify the decree degrees of freedom
we just give it a prize as a uniform
within some range is a rig is a pretty
poorly chosen prior but it would work
for now and also I do the sample size
one so that I don't need to do kind of
locked or shake Jacqueline's in setting
up the distribution later on and when it
similarly it keeps you in check the
graph and make sure that oh actually it
has a right dependency and also here you
can observe that because we have the
degrees of freedom has been the last
distribution that we specify it comes
with the first argument and then P 1 and
then B 0 and we can validate that this
is correct and we can do samples and
this is prior predict examples of of
what the kind of outcome will apply and
again we can do a maximum likelihood but
here because the optimizer will assume
that all your parameters is live in this
continuous space so you actually need to
to do the transformation so that is it
it satisfied the route API requirement
so I'm using the interval
transformations I was this is a kind of
like a basic setup of how you would
write a projector but I would skip
through this part for now and just to
show you that this will also give you
maximum likelihood estimations and now
that the by ejector is actually
important when we are calling a sample
us because what the sample
sample our agency samah hamiltonian
monte carlo in general it also requires
you at least in most case for the
program to work correctly is that all
the three parameters it should be on
discontinuous real light so the the API
to do this is that we use this called a
change transfer transitional kernel
which I'll go back which is that you
pass unconstrained by chapter here and
it will it will come word the log plot
function internally into a functions
that leaves basically is unconstrained
all the parameters and it because it
does the bookkeeping internally for
example make sure that the Jacobian is
correct and also makes sure the
transformation is correct the output
sample is always kind of in the correct
range so the untransformed correct
parameters never directly exposed
right so this is quite similar to what
we would do for the as the sample for
the for the other models and while these
runs
I was keep to the next X finish this one
is actually running a bit slow okay
so if you once you kind of like get more
into Bayesian modeling and you'll find
that you can always there's lots of time
no see
Diagnostics comes with office and is
really state-of-the-art because the
developers are actively implementing new
diagnosis and also keep up to tape is
kind of like was a best practice so for
those parts at least refer to the to the
obvious kind of libraries and I'm not
sure how much time I have but okay so I
keep going so here is another example is
is from the baseball data of 18 players
from out front and basically is kind of
like we want to infer the ability of
each baseball player and here the model
setup you can look at the pump see free
dogs to see that why we are setting up
the distribution like this but here it's
just basically just a taste of what you
would do and this I don't think there's
much of the things that we haven't seen
today but some things that I want to
point out before we wrap up this session
is that before we are using the API of
the optimizer just input a kind of like
scalar function right so we basically
get out the output as just one feed but
actually the API itself is also part
which means that if you want to run this
optimization like a hundred of times you
can just do one pass to the functions so
what I mean is that when you set up the
log prop function correctly as a batch
version for example
and you you do need to squeeze it to
make theirs yeah some shape handling
again but the kind of the trick here is
that now then it actually runs in part
as well so you can do this kind of line
top optimizer converge any which means
that if any times that optimizes say
things that is converge you can output
the result and you can even do converged
of all to force that the optimizer
finish or terminate only when it all the
result converge and in this waste
basically it's a great way to check that
if you have different initialization of
the optimizer whether they all converge
to the same result and it can it can
always be that it can also be the case
that if you have multiple starting
points from the posterior space which
one kind of like if you converge the
fastest and you can get resolved much
quicker however in this case is that at
the low prob
sorry the because the posterior space is
actually quite difficult to do
optimization so you would actually not
have any convergence and if you kind of
clock out if it's converge or switch
fail everything is fair but if you have
like other programs that you actually
wants to look at to find a maximum
likelihood or to just find some loss
function you want to find the maximum
this is in general quite good ways to do
this patch kind of optimizations
right so distance does not converge so I
will actually do samples from here and I
will skip through this examples so but
please if you want to kind of like see
how each of them works please play
around with it after the sessions and
then here is another example I
personally find it quite important
because a mixture kind of distribution
is always kind of quite difficult things
to set up I always like to think that
when you have a mixture models is kind
of like ultimate challenge for any
public program libraries because the
broadcasting here is exceptionally
tricky so here I have some hypothetical
scenario is that I have basically asked
multiple reviewers to labels and items
and we have some unknown about to latent
labels so in a way this is kind of like
quite a bitter Bernoulli mixture model
and here is the kind of like the problem
setup so I have five reviewers I have
the true fraction of my bad events or
labels that are positive labels or you
can think of it and I have the number of
examples actually being revealed and
after some parameter transformation I
can draw can apply generate a random
fake data of what the observation will
looks like and here this is some
signature of how you set up a mixture
distributions in terms of all
probability so we need mixture weight
but you always need to pass it as a
categorical and we need all the
components which is comes
and here the important thing is to use
the independent here but I think it
probably also work with Tao when we are
just doing a samples but a lot of proper
not be correct most likely and there are
some shake juggler in somewhere
but at least for now we don't need to do
that because we just draw in one random
sample from it or in a way it's not a
bad version of random samples now that
if you want to move it into into the
joint distribution is a bit more
complicated because now we need to make
sure that the shape is working correctly
so I think one of the most differences
between the the ones that you see it
from above is that you just need to make
sure the concatenations is correct in
this case
right and we can also do similar things
to do draw a sample from it and look at
how the output sample size alpha size
looks like and one of the kind of right
tricks I I always use is that because we
have our observe and it's jet that is
just one instant and we want it to be
broadcast correctly into the lock rod
basically we want or the batch of the
lock lock condition correctly on
observations so and of course the
easiest case we is repeated so that the
first dimensions is the same but
otherwise we just pad that it should Pat
the shape of the input array so that is
it at least have the same rank and the
rest of the the size of still the same
and now we do the same of checking the
the path each part of the law products
and we'll do inference similarly
right okay so last example for the day
is the kind of mixed mixed effect model
from the very famous radon data set so
this is kind of like the models that I
personally like the most because mix
effect model is surprisingly powerful
and it include most of the use case that
I personally encounter again I'm not
going to detail of how the data set
looks like here you can read it more
following the links and here's just how
you will ride our models so we will have
to also the priors and here in this case
they don't have any dependency so these
are kind of like straightforward and we
have kind of this random effect and then
we also have the fix effect and we were
at the end have this huge functions
basically to do this of the linear
transformation and this is usually the
things that is takes the longest time to
set up correctly because now that not
only we need to make sure the shape is
well actually ninety percent of the time
is to make sure the shape is is correct
and so here I actually need to do some
transpose to also do some gathers
because here the county is index or kind
of vector and and I also need to
interpret the batch dimension because as
we see in other examples similarly we
are broadcasting into number of
observations so that we need to make
sure that we do some is computed
correctly
right and all the rest of the checks is
kind of like goes very similar and the
most important part is again here that
you want it to be - you want the log
drop to make sure the log progress
actually compute correctly by checking
the each part of the the log proximal
neural functions and don't think I would
have enough time to to go through all
the rest of the call but here basically
is is to do this kind of mean view a DVI
by using the Joint Distribution class
so I recommend you to have a look
afterwards
basically if you are interested in
variation of inference the joint
distribution is quite a good interface
for you to write these variational
approximations or vibrational
distributions and the tense of
rockabilly team is actively trying to
make this even more natural even easier
to set up so you can follow through this
afterward and also just as kind of what
difference was the differences or in
terms of like MCMC sample here is that
we reset the function here because I'm
not only that I am using the twin sample
means I also have kind of additional
additional tuning for the mass matrix so
for example here is some code to
initialize with the meaning in few advi
and what I was doing is that I first fit
the mean few IDBI and I get kind of get
some and then add a sample from the
variational
distributions and I compute the standard
deviation and use that as the step size
or alternately you can do this mass
measures adaptation which you you throw
a few samples and then you compute the
mean and standard deviation of the
posterior and you plug that back in and
sample it again and it's kind of nice
still in an early stage of developing
the API but basically this is kind of
how stands or time see free is doing so
as kind of like a more advanced or
practice if you you rather call it is
that you can try to rewrite this into
every
in tensorflow because now you see that
I'm actually using a followed and
repeatedly calling this function but
ways to to not materialize all the
chains and do the computation and to
example just doing the running means or
running called covariance estimations
and then write these whole things into
tfy loop so that we have a coherent API
to to do the adaptation and the sample
means afterward so yeah have a lot of it
afterward and you can if you are
interest you can try to use it as
homework and basically do the rewrite of
the functions so so here there's more or
less all of it for me today
I didn't go into too much too much
detail of the last example because
there's a lot of details and it might be
might we will definitely take too long
to explain everything but yet any
questions so far
so if you have follow-up questions
especially in terms of like oh I want to
implement my own model but I cannot get
a broadcasting right you can search on
the tensorflow probability that was a
forum that you can post question yes
I think while hear you correctly but if
I so you're asking why you would use
this API instead of like higher level
API right I'll great questions I think
as the data scientists of course we use
whatever we have that is to our jobs the
most efficient right I've been a good
thing of use intensive probability is
that is in the tensor flow ecosystem
which means that if you want the
production I production eyes this kind
of model is much easier and it also
comes with good integrations of
hardware's
so for example if you want to train on
TV you or you want to train efficiently
on GPU it has much more opportunity
there and also I think one of the it
also opened new doors for doing research
as well because now with this kind of
bad shape native concept that everything
is part you can do of things that is
generally impossible to do currently in
any other kinds of framework because for
example in time c3 or Stan all the
chains you cannot communicate with each
other so for example if you want to do
this replica on the kalos a replica
exchange Monte Carlo which requires you
to talk across chain it's only kind of
doable intensive program now otherwise
you need to grow out your own kind of
implementations I want to ground under
now when I move around the mass I ever
wanna show
hi thank you so much for the for the
presentation so I I would like to us so
I are there some use cases for which
you're using this API in Google or is
there something in plan this again is
being used in production to solve some
problems some sorry I think I gotcha
so my question is basically is this so
what kind of problems or what are some
use cases uh-huh that that might be
being solved at Google or you might have
solved using vision programs as compared
to some alternatives method we have like
tree based models so able to understand
on the apply right right yeah quick
question I think if you go to youtube
recently there's a few presentation by
the tensor proteins especially by for
material Josh he gives a few example of
like what is the kind of rewrite view
like applications that you can do with
tangible probability and I think some of
it is really interesting again check out
the talks but basically for example
those they have used it to solve to
reduce the fuel efficient to improve the
fuel efficiency for jak engines so I
think that one of those a really
impressive example of how you use it to
solve real life questions otherwise in
general rules I mean any kinds of
patient model that you are running or
even I would crane the statistical
models because as a patient we always
like to think everything is patient you
can do for example I AP testing and the
advantage of using tens of probability
is that because is it takes advantage of
this tensor for ecosystem it means that
when you have large data is it handle it
much more gracefully instead apply if
you are using other frameworks you might
run into a problem if you have like
millions of data points tens of millions
of users so
I think that would be one of the
advantage of like why you want to
implement it or look at this lower level
of implementations because you have much
more control and also it comes with
advantage of being a patient basically
so you can incorporate it your prior
information so that's kind of like
general advantage of using using patient
statistics
[Music]